c'est très symbolique quand on passe ce
portail on est coupé du monde il a
vraiment une réalité concrète des choses
que vous faites de faire un projet là
dessus sont vraiment impliqués
c'est important de savoir ce qui s'est
passé avant que ça se reproduise hausse
sera plus qu ils ont vécu non pas les
oublier au final
[Musique]
en ce matin gris du mois de novembre les
élèves au rendez vous aux archives
départementales de la côte d'or
ils vont remonter le temps démonter les
mécanismes administratifs du
gouvernement de vichy et explorer les
tréfonds de la société française
pendant ces années noires au prend son
temps on est là comme pendant au moins
deux heures donc il ya le temps de bien
s'approprier les documents professeur
d'histoire au lycée charles de gaulle
dimitri vous elle est aussi chargée du
service éducatif aux archives
départementales les documents qu'il a
préparés sont des originaux
les filles de recensement des familles
juives les procès verbaux d'arrestations
et des transferts à drancy pour la
première fois les élèves vont tenir
entre leurs mains des preuves du passé
ou quoi c'est dû 10 90 w 41 et donc
c'est parti pour la pochette mais à
l'intérieur et les documents très
précieux il ya eu des documents
officiels qui ont été sélectionnés pour
qu'ils comprennent que c'est une
politique d'état à la fois qui vient des
allemands et qu'il ya aussi du régime de
vichy et puis ensuite il ya eu des
documents qui a été choisi pour
reconstituer des histoires personnelles
pour qu'ils comprennent que bien sûr il
ya la grande histoire mais derrière ces
mesures générales
il y a aussi des destins particuliers
des 17 avril inscrit noir sur blanc sur
des feuilles jaunies le passé ressurgit
aux yeux de cette génération née au
début des années 2000 plus de soixante
dix ans après la seconde guerre mondiale
décryptage prise de notes
les lycéens font un travail d'historien
les 400 militants
pour les juifs qui sont mises à
disposition le gouvernement français
quatre cent mille étoiles j'ai fait de
lire d'avoir des documents officiels qui
nous font que c'est vraiment vrai c'est
aussi strictes
et c'est tout blanc alors donc vous
allez travailler vos sur trois rafle qui
ont dû abidjan guidés par leur
professeur et à l'aide d'un
questionnaire les élèves cherchent à
comprendre comment le piège s'est
refermé sur des citoyens devenus
indésirables dans la zone occupée par
l'allemagne nazie
voilà ce qui était demandé exactement
pas requise et femme et moi je trouve
que ça on les choses réelles en est elle
ressentie de certaines personnes qui ont
été déportés on voit qui on a demandé de
venir se présenter leur sortie certains
étaient révoltés d'autres d'autres
semblent trouver ça normal donc voilà au
met
en décembre soit quand même quand tout
commence une lettre envoyée aux préfets
je suis français avant tout et je juge
de mon devoir de de porter à votre
connaissance un fait scandaleux 1 la
commune de saint germain les sonnailles
ils étaient pas admis ce trait par son
hummer qui vient de mourir
mais en fait par une juive est donc ce
courrier il va déclencher quoi vous
allez voir les documents suivants il va
déclencher la fois l'art avant d'errer
qu'elle prouve qu'elle est française
sauf que vous allez voir le pape a donc
d'avoir un courrier ou un journal hier
matin vous a pas pu le prouver il va
falloir que vous portiez sur les 320
mille juifs environ qui vivait en france
en 1940 76000 dans onze mille quatre
cents enfants ont été déportés
leurs noms ont été répertoriés par serge
klarsfeld
dans un livre le mémorial de la
déportation des juifs de france des non
inscrits sur un mur à paris au mémorial
de la shoah que ces jeunes dijonnais ont
visité vous voyez toutes les personnes
en france qui avaient été déportés
il y avait aussi le maire des enfants
donc avec beaucoup de photos d'enfants
qui ont été déportés et tués
toutes ces choses permettent en fait de
retracer la mémoire de ces personnes les
faire revivre
certains sens ne pas les oublier au
final cette connaissance de l'histoire
de la shoah
les élèves vont l'approfondir encore en
allant à prague en visitant l'usiné
d'oskar schindler les camps de
concentration de terezin et d'auschwitz
[Musique]